hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my legends of tomorrow episode 9
video just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet the big deal with
this episode was that they brought back
the Matt Nabal Rachel Cole and they
introduced the Talia al Ghul character I
know everybody's always wondered if
Talia exists in this universe they've
done a lot of weird things like saying
that super girls on a different earth so
now it's official Talia's somewhere in
this universe she's a lot older than
Nyssa and I'll talk a little bit about
what the producers have said about her
in the past they've just said in the
past that Nyssa is always going to be
their go-to sister just because they're
so happy with what Katrina law has done
with the character so even if Talia does
come on the show as an adult in the
future it's always gonna be a very minor
thing compared to any stories that they
do with Nyssa so if you're wondering why
we haven't seen Halle on modern day one
it's because they haven't really found
the right story for her as at least as
an adult and two it's because they've
already spent so much time developing
the Nyssa character if you're wondering
how much older Talia is she looks like
she's maybe 10 years old in this so 10
years old in 1960 if Oliver was born in
1985 and Nyssa is about the same age as
Oliver then that would mean that Talia
is almost 35 years older than her so we
saw her in modern-day unless they had
some sort of fancy Lazarus Pit explainer
where she's stayed young all this time
she's in her early 60s but if Rachael
Ghul has been using the Lazarus Pit this
whole time
Talia's probably been using it too so
they could introduce a young looking
Talia who is just chronologically very
old so wrap your brain around that but
let's do top five WTF and Easter eggs
there were a couple big comic book
Easter eggs starting with number 5
Hawker only Adam settle in Hub City he
becomes a professor we actually see Bill
Gates father which is funny but Hub City
is a big city in DC Comics is where the
question is from it appears during the
Blue Beetle comics the first time Hub
City was mentioned in a comic was during
Blue Beetle number one during 1967 so
they're in Hub City in the 60s so
they're essentially living in a Blue
Beetle comic book right now but I will
say one of my least favorite things
about the episode was this forced
relationship with Kendra and Ray I get
that over a period of time they would
just come to terms with it and try to
make a life together but the problem is
is that they rush it so much that you
miss the montage
so it'd be like watching Batman vs
Superman and just fast-forwarding all
the way to the end of the movie you
would have no context for Batman's
emotional art so definitely thumbs down
on Hawkgirl Adam romance I'm totally not
digging their chemistry so I feel like
on the back end of this we're gonna see
some more drama when Hawkman does
reappear and he is going to come back on
the series he reincarnates so even
though he's dead he will totally come
back
number four WTF Sarah goes back to the
future she rejoins the League of
Assassins goes totally hardcore in they
did kind of explain why she was so
whacked out so many of the characters
were acting very strangely like even
though chronologically a very small
amount of time had passed they were
acting very out of character
the way they explained it was the time
drift the more time they spent in this
alternate timeline the more they forgot
their previous lives so that's why it
seemed like some of them had drunk the
kool-aid but that's really a band-aid
for them kind of fast-forwarding through
the character beats that they needed to
hit to make it believable that like
Sarah for instance went super dark like
oh they're never gonna come I'm just
gonna go be a killer again it felt like
they tried to undercut all the character
development she had gone through before
the series had started becoming the
white canary and then explaining it
using this time drift I understand what
they were going for in this episode but
that was one of my big complaints is
that it's rushing so much character
development but whatever we got cool
League of Assassins I feel like that was
the pitch like hey what if she went back
to the League of Assassins sping you
which number three WTF Chronos reveals
that he's really heatwave everybody who
gets this ahead of time high-five
yourselves I noticed a lot of you guys
were like yeah that's definitely
heatwave it's gotta be him and it took a
little while for the episode to get
there but I felt like the last moment
where they were like okay we're gonna
rehabilitate him I feel like that
emotional beat actually worked so
they're gonna deprogram heatwave he'll
just go back to being normal crazy he's
extra crazy now they're gonna bring him
back to normal crazy number two WTF this
was just vicious heatwave when he's
still like in the Chronos persona tells
captain cold that the great thing about
time travel is that he gets to kill his
sister over and over what has made him
so psychotic really his given mission is
just to bring in rip hunter to stop him
from messing with a timeline so when
he's talking to Captain Cold here
he's gone totally off-book he's totally
insane so a lot of this did not make
sense like they didn't really explain
why even though he's a bounty hunter
working for the time masters he's gone
crazy on top of that he started out as
this unbalanced rogue went nuts trying
to survive till the time masters found
him reconditioned him over a long period
of years so he lived many years outside
the flow of time then when given the
opportunity to bring his former friends
in he jumped on it he's like yeah I'll
totally bring him in I hate those guys
but then when he finally gets them he
goes way off book and it's like I'm just
gonna go do the Cisco 12 monkeys loop
where I get to kill your sister over and
over and over and then my number one WTF
moment is just captain cold shooting his
hand off well really he freezes it and
then smashes it but I love that reaction
shot of him where rip is like oh I
didn't tell you
I can totally regrow your hand and he
just gives them that look like oh okay
cool and they've already announced that
one of the actors from suits one of the
main actors is playing this huge
comic-book character that's gonna set
off their season two arc and I don't
know who it's gonna be
it could be Booster Gold that'd be a
long shot I think it's more likely that
he'd be Adam Strange but they did say
he'd be a really big character from the
comics I don't know when they're gonna
announce that they might hold on to it
till comic-con who knows well let me
know in the comments what was your
favorite moment from this episode was
the Captain Cold shooting his hand off
then regrowing it was it finally seeing
Talia al Ghul in the TV universe I would
really love if on a future season of
arrow they did like a Nyssa versus Talia
story arc I feel like this season
they've kind of destroyed the League of
Assassins they've officially disbanded I
feel like at some point in the future
like arrow season 5 or something like
that
Talia will reach try to reform the
league and they can do a badass Nyssa
vs. Talia arc those of you that are
asking about Jonah Hex that's gonna be
their magnificent 7 episode I think
that's going to be in two weeks
flash is on break right now there is a
new episode of arrow next week and I
believe there's new episode of legends
of tomorrow so Jonah Hex coming really
soon there's actually 16 episodes total
this season this was episode 9 so we
actually still have quite a ways to go
my next video will be a flash trailer
video it's gonna be all about zooms
backstory so I can't wait till the next
episode of the flash it's gonna be
badass
so be sure to subscribe to get that in
worry I will do flash bonus videos while
it's on break why you guys wait for me
to post that video you can click here
for this week's episode of the flash and
you can click here for the Suicide Squad
trail that I just posted thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight